c'était le choc à ne pas manquer ce
week-end dans les Yvelines en Fédérale 2
Versailles recevait plaisir dans un
derby qui s'annonçait sulfureux entre
deux équipes du top 6 de la poule en
première période les plaisirs prennent
rapidement l'ascendant avec un essai dès
la quatrième minute de jeu
mais Versailles reste dans le match
grâce à des pénalités et les joueurs de
la cité royale passent devant avec cet
essai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plaisir égalisant ensuite juste avant la
mi-temps cesse partout ce sera le score
à la pause une première mi-temps alors
une bonne entame de match mais on prend
le score on est bien par contre
effectivement après on prend un carton
donc on passe 15 minutes effectivement
dominé bon on prend un essai casquette
là d'ailleurs j'attends de voir la vidéo
parce que je pense que moi qui a hors
jeu sur le drop c'est bon mais à voir
effectivement
cet essai nous fait mal effectivement et
en fin de premier temps on a quelques
occasions ou on fait n'importe quoi
malheureusement mais on aurait pu être
devant à la mi-temps on a de la chance
de donner ses casquettes qui nous permet
de revenir de revenir au score donc
finalement on a un peu de chance je
dirais d'arriver à égalité à la mi-temps
mais on pense de ça comme ciné destin
mais finalement nous avons aussi bien
servi qu'on l'aurait cru en effet en
seconde période plaisir accélère et
marque deux essais pendant les 40
minutes Versailles n'arrivera pas à
revenir dans la partie le score final 30
à 19 dans une ambiance sulfureuse
[Applaudissements]
déjà très très content de gagner parce
que on savait que ça allait être un peu
un match piège ici qu'on était fortement
attendu ça a été le cas une grosse
grosse pression des Versaillais ils ont
mis tout leur cœur donc effectivement il
a fallu quand même qu'on s'emploie
fortement et c'est une belle victoire à
22 joueurs aujourd'hui c'était un match
de tableaux clairement puisque plaisir
et deuxième bon voilà on était dans le
match je pense toute la toute la partie
et puis les matchs de notre tableau ça
joue sur sur des détails et aujourd'hui
on a manqué un petit peu de maîtrise
pour aller chercher la gagne voilà pas
mal de cartons et un petit peu de manque
de maîtrise dans dans les zones de
marque au classement les plaisirs
restent à la deuxième place à un point
du leader Le Havre les versets sont
quant à eux toujours 6e la prochaine
journée de Fédérale 2 et programmé ce
dimanche 29 janvier plaisir recevra
Amiens et Versailles Ris-Orangis
[Applaudissements]